we're now working our way up toward the
top end of the Khumbu glacier we're
trying to establish a route through
these crevasses to get to the foot of
the lucky face and that's where we're
all or the next few days start stringing
rope to camp three and then eventually
up to camp four inside now we have been
preparing the ruffs and all the Sherpas
are here we're going to be important
Sherpas for 15 days tomorrow
there are Sherpas from different
companies although they are very good
strong so our job now is sixteen lines
on the case well I think we're some of
the first people up here there's a
little bit of old fixed line from last
season but not enough to clip it into
some pretty big curve asses here so
we're being conservative eventually I
think another week or so this will be
all fixed you can just clip in with a
beaner and not have to worry about
roping up I think there's gonna be it
for today we're at about 22,000 and
maybe just a little change but we like
it sweet up to here and from here on up
it's gonna be six lines
Oh